Filmmaker Don Swanson of Occurrence At Mills
Creek Movie: Hi!
My name is Don Swanson and I’m the writer
and director of Occurrence At Mills Creek
Movie.
We are currently running an Indiegogo campaign
to raise funds to make a feature film based
on a short film.
Which certainly isn’t anything new but our
approach is kind of unique to it that our
short film is in actuality the opening act
of the feature film.
All of this started back in 2016 when I was
working on another project with a young actress
named Alexa Mechling.
And she was being kind of hyper or whatever
and so I joked with her and said that if she
didn’t settle down I was going to write
a script where her throat.
And about a year and a half later she asked
me what was going on with that idea and basically
at the time we had come off of that feature,
had done another project and quite honestly
I was pretty tired and was just looking to
do something kind of fun on a weekend where
we could do some cool, cool horror stuff.
And the idea that I came up with was what
is the worst fate that a daughter could suffer.
And in my mind that would be emotionally and
psychically and mentally tormented and betrayed
by her mother and so that’s where the throat
came in and everything.
The idea that a mom was messing with her daughter,
kind of punishing her mentally and emotionally
before taking the price of her life.
And I kind of worked on the script and got
it to a pretty good point and some people
became aware of it.
And that’s how we landed Betsy Lynn George
ultimately and it was actually Betsy who suggest
maybe it was the sister because she saw the
mom as more of a caregiver and as soon as
we took that direction all of these different
threads started to grow out of it and before
long I had so much kind of backstory and possibility
for these characters that it was well beyond
the base concept of a 10 minute character
of thriller piece dealing with that moment
before the daughter’s death.
And we kind of took off based on the people
who were getting involved and everything and
we realized that there was so much more to
the story.
Not just bulking up that bit but that it was
just like a chunk of a story.
So kind of like went and restructured that
to bring a little more depth to the characters
that were involved and these ideas of where
it could go, what it could all possibly mean.
As the short kind of came into focus it became
apparent that it was more psychological than
horror and it was more family drama.
And with that being the case there was much
more to tell than just that little bit.
I had been involved on crowdfunding projects
before.
More in like a support kind of role.
This is the first time that I’ve been the
person responsible for it and in charge of
it.
But in both of those instances we had something
to show.
One that I did with a collaborator John-Patrick
Driscoll in 2012.
We’d shot the short and were seeking funds
to complete it.
And one that I helped out with Tom Willimas
and Chris Lee.
We actually shot a very professional and very
structured concept trailer using who was going
to be our talent and everything.
And from that experience I learned that you
want to have something to show (if at all
possible).
You don’t just want to get up there and
be like “Hi!
I’m so-and-so.
I have a great idea and you should give me
money.”
We wanted to actually show something.
And also if we could see if it would potentially
work.
My initial plan was to let the film play the
festival circuit for about 6 months or so
to kind of build some buzz, some awareness
(things like that) and then go into the crowdfunding.
But as it kept progressing, more and more
people found out about it.
More people wanted to be involved with it.
And basically we’d just kind of gotten to
place where it would work against us to wait
more than it would help.
The way that it was structured is the last
scene of the short film is designed to work
in two ways (literally just two or three shots)
changed the entire scene.
One version ends the short and it keeps it
exploring kind of a psychological illness
and disillusionment.
And the other one springboards it to what
could be one or two years in the future.
And it picks up again where the character
Clara (played by Ava Psoras is actually working
through the issues that she experiences in
the short.
In that way it’s almost like a sequel to
the short but it’s told in one story and
the short in and of itself explores these
themes.
It is a complete story.
It has the beginning, middle and end but ends
on a more ambiguous, challenge you to think
about reality kind of way.
Whereas by tweaking the last scene, it gives
us a springboard to jump into the future and
basically see the effect that all of this
had on Clara.
And then it gives us even more fun to play
around with her in a psychological sense because
then we get to do all kinds of things where
what’s real and what wasn’t real?
What from the short actually happened?
What from the short didn’t actually happen
and her entire reality gets to be blurred.
And so basically the short is centered around
this whole idea of her dealing with guilt
over the sister, we take that and we just
like run wild with it in the feature.
We begin to pick away her reality.
We’re able to give her a life and take it
away from her.
We’re able to give some kind of backstory,
some kind of a depth to her family because
at the root of it is really is about these
three girls.
And we’re really able to get into those
notions of family.
And it’s really cool because we’re concentrating
on these female characters specifically and
we’re looking for kind of mother and daughter
relationships (sister relationships) and we’re
adding this kind of stress, this kind of family
dynamic which is dramatic by nature and we’re
putting it in a horror blanket except we’re
kind of playing with it psychologically.
So basically we set Clara up in the short
and we knock her all over the place in the
feature.
And we take all of these ideas and we run
with them further and we kind of complete
that story.
We are using the same footage, we are using
the same actors.
I mean that was the plan once we start rolling
on the short.
That this would be one quarter of the film.
We’re independent, we’re very independent.
We’re ultra-low budget.
Everyone who is working on this is because
it’s a passion project of some sort.
We all believe in what we’re doing and ultimately
we don’t have the luxury or the time to
reshoot anything actually.
We were able to basically restructure the
opening act from the short film so Ava is
still Clara.
Betsy Lynn George is still Emily.
Alexa Mechling is still Cassandra.
Some other actors who appeared in the short
are also coming back for the feature including
Joe Fischell as Victor (Emily’s husband
and the girl’s father).
Lynda Marnoni who worked with George Romero
in the 70’s in THE CRAZIES and SEASON OF
THE WITCH is coming back as Anastelle as well
as some others.
So yes, all of the same actors.
All of the same footage.
It’s quite literally two or three shots
that transition the short.
The short is as stands the opening to the
feature with those few changes.
So as I said before my initial idea was to
wait 6 months to a year before going on with
the feature.
But we had so many amazing opportunities kind
of present themselves such as Mia Zanotti
and other cast members and other opportunities
and places to shoot that it would actually
hurt us to wait.
So the short film is being used as our ability
to show we’re more than just an idea.
We’re doing this, we’ve done this, we’ve
started this.
And that’s probably fro my personal experience
in crowdfunding the biggest piece of advice
any filmmaker who is looking to do it on any
level.
But be more than just a talking head saying
we’ve got this great idea.
Have something to show even if you have to
rack up the credit card a little bit to put
together some kind of a concept trailer with
the talent you hope to use, have something
to show.
So ultimately the way it ended up playing
out where we are, the short film for us is
something to show.
It’s our start, it’s our ability to say
we’re doing this.
It’s not just an idea, it’s something
that actually is happening.
And people can get a sense of what we’re
about and what we’re doing based off of
that and then decide for themselves if they
think we’re worth supporting or not, which
of course, I hope they do.